I remember being broke I know it is
money I'm gonna go like where everybody
goes I remember sleeping on the floor
everything huge day for me man just
because I don't keep musicians or anyone
but garyvee I'm such a huge fan you
could tell I got my back man and the way
you said Vaynerchuk um that's the tale
I'm like okay guys he's in I appreciate
rap super-interesting is you're like
you're like the you like the ANR of
entrepreneurs you know what I mean
you're like the dude like you see all
the entrepreneurs out there you're
giving them advice you know very similar
in the music industry but now you're
actually bringing artists to your office
you're sitting down with tea grizzly and
having like 30 minute conversations and
putting them on your YouTube did you
think when you were starting you know
Wine Library you know doing doing
YouTube videos about wine you'd be
sitting down with the biggest superstars
in music like giving them advice if you
told me that I'd be the coolest I ever
was at 42 years old it's so crazy it's
fun to have Mike Boyd here in the corner
Mike went to college with my brother AJ
and literally for the last decade in
some shape or form
I've been bankrolling and we've been
jamming on hacking enjoying managing
creating [ __ ] first we started a first
he I don't wanna say we I paid but he
started a blog called hip hop at lunch
he was writing articles about Wiz
Khalifa Nicki Minaj and Mac Miller and
nipsey hussle long before they became
who they were so I'm like okay he
clearly knows then he worked at
vaynermedia then I helped him get a job
somewhere else then he came back and
then it's just it's really everything he
came back and it was no thought really
it was more of like oh and then we
managed then we managed Rome fortune Wow
then he came back and was like it was
really just a like after two years of
Rome just like living the management
life trying to break an artist big shout
out to the room fortune you know like
him him just coming back he's like you
don't want to eat another cool off
period let's just let me just work at
vaynermedia for two years and we'll be
set I don't think either one of us could
have saw that I would start penetrating
it makes sense right as he as
entrepreneurship and business yeah have
been built up as as I Geist the way an
athlete and a rapper now all of a sudden
you're in that conversation and much
just like athletes and rappers commingle
like Joel embiid wants a
five Meek Mill as much as Meek Mill
wants a high five JoEllen bead now the
entrepreneur is part of that
conversation so for me to think that
like Kelly or like gonna or you know
tiara whack or whoever it is like they
think I'm cool like that's funny to me
and what's real fun for me back to your
a in our part but you mean Boyd's
ability to do in music between my funny
ear where like I kind of know what
everybody's gonna like and then to your
point knowing when I sit down with
peewee like does he have it or yg do
they have the business chest and what's
funny is you can be a great like when I
Stella T grizzly I know that he's well
on his way to being a big-time hip hop
artist but when you're walking into my
room that wall that room you're coming
to talk business
yeah and so for me I may like your music
but if you suck at business I'm gonna
let you know right and I'm gonna but
more important they're not gonna let you
know by like dis tracking you I'm gonna
try to be like no have you thought about
this have you Nicky Jam if you really
want you're an entrepreneur and you want
to really let me phrase if you're
listening right now and you're an artist
that is also not trippin or or just an
entrepreneur you have to watch that
interview because there I really break
down and if Nicky goes and executes what
I told him to do he'll be in a different
place I think you should be thinking
about getting equity in a start-up
beverage like dirty lemon who's smart
enough to know that you're exactly what
they need you get a point of the company
on the back end they market you properly
not on dumb billboards she's doubt
Vennela out right and you win twice or
somebody's super artistic like Big KRIT
right if you go watch the krint
interview if he goes and listens to what
I I'm gonna do he'll be put on in a more
artistic business way I have a concept
that I haven't seen okay song comes out
album comes out project comes out
something pops in movies they come out
with number two quick you put out right
guardians of the galaxy you're like what
the [ __ ] I'm in it blows up in the
theater they're [ __ ] in production on
number two
so so for me again back to lyrics okay
you write a song it's about what you're
going through with your girl with your
best friend but somebody's sick in your
family and it goes well it's been some
time in between you writing that and now
it happening to write the update and
piggyback off the momentum is something
I've never seen
whereas Nikki may make the kind of money
that you know know if you really listen
to what I said he's gonna make dr. dre
beats money okay people are hitting me
on if she's a real businessman - correct
and he's awesome like I'll tell you that
nipsey is more of a psychologist and
kind of uh you know a thinker that way
trading culture a hundred percent that's
basically all I think about
attention arbitrage hat culture then
you're good and so I I win on psychology
the reason I can go from the boardroom
on Madison Avenue to the studio in the
hood and like Rallo
they just don't do it what does it be
everybody could be richer taper they
mind I ain't no better than this man
I got the same hair same same
if you ever looked at my calendar where
I'm like meeting a 68 year old
billionaire you know CEO of like you
know Budweiser and then four hours later
I'm in studio Rallo I'm playing so high
low but the one connective tissue is
that I'm trying to bring people value
and I have empathy
I believe you man because you know
watching your videos and watching you
you go out you know your day to day life
you don't change whether you're in a
billion dollar meeting or the CEO or
you're in with Rallo or young bands are
kilee
it's Gary beef all the time and what's
interesting is one could be listening
right now and be like yeah but he can
edit it like the only person who really
knows that is iris in the room
yeah oh sure yeah she's with me all the
time like rock and babban and they're
the ones that really know and you're
right because I don't give a [ __ ] look
here's what I would say you can't be
authentic if you pander to anything
other than yourself like the reason
people break through is whether through
their own like weird this or adversity
or you know so I love it why the tea
grisly breakthrough [ __ ] jail for
four years so I get locked up off the
rig my first time one a prison I was in
the holiday for state very far away
[ __ ] second and like he got sent to a
bunch of different jails and he started
picking up on flavor outside of Detroit
you know you get to talking to people
you get to mingle and you get emotions
off your own I'm not only house on their
rapid which I owe you something
mmm-hmm so I'll rat form I'll grab some
stuff that everybody in city loves and I
was like alright hang here day okay oh
maybe that's what's missing like damn I
don't connect back to this some super
Detroit sit anybody spin it in the yard
and I got slack because he used the
terminology for a car that other people
didn't use because that's how they
setting the trend so what happened was
he got empathy
I don't like up in so many different
states it is one time like I had like
it's moving you yeah they kept on moving
me so you fill your fan base and gotten
look who you like literally crafted it
and got context that exact
[ __ ] sense when he came out he
understood a lot of different people now
we can make a hit right but the kid in
Detroit right now who's gonna copy T
grizzly lost because he's not authentic
already and that speaks to patience
yeah right like he had to give up four
years of his life have the stigma of
being locked up all the things come
along with this slowed everything down
but it opened up another opportunity do
you have a good time her own lab I had a
great time man what was give me like
give me what what struck you who I want
to say rich the kid when we're just
seeing the response to someone like rich
and you know I've been a fan I've been a
fan for a few years and I've kind of
followed him throughout you know his
whole his whole career and so just to
see the the payoff the reward you know
he hacked boy there's one of the first
meetings we had was with rich and you
know that's a two and a half years ago
now but like now hip-hop kids have any
one hundred millionaires cuz they're
getting out there trying to like to play
at the highest levels just like athletes
you go back to 60s and 70s athletes were
they had jobs in the offseason right
like corner like the biggest
quarterbacks in the 5060 70s they hope
to coach when they were done now these
quarterbacks
they want to own the team you know hip
hop kids coming up 20 years ago they're
like oh maybe I'll get like a good deal
now they want to own the label they want
to own a fashion brand sneaker deals
startup companies like everybody's in
for whatever and that's huge it's been
changing so for me the big thing now is
what I want to be and I think it's so
fun to say it right here right now here
if I can be the Jimmy Iovine to the
default to all of them if they're all
Dre that's why I'm meeting all of them
and you know I don't know how wired in
or what you've heard or not heard I'm
not asking for [ __ ] yeah I don't want
anything if I can be the Jimmy to all
this collective if you're 15 to 30 and
you're going to you're about to hit or
you're kind of coming up if I can just
keep spitting value into the system
that's gonna work out and whether you're
far along like nipsey and yg where I can
talk about that
next next step or when bands came into
my office he still got something around
his [ __ ] ankle you clearly had your
[ __ ] together the only thing that's
gonna [ __ ] you up is cuz you know it's
gonna happen you can feel it and
sometimes youngsters are just like [ __ ]
why hasn't it happened like 13 months
from now like happen like that song that
completely changed [ __ ] and then they
start doing short cuts this I'm telling
you Gunners know New York's very simple
hey free city where's my 20 bucks look
listen I know we're talking a lot about
music which is probably the most I've
talked about music dude but I'm saying
like this is why I wanted you on the
show because you know what the [ __ ]
you're talking abut I I know about it in
some interesting ways so for example
somebody who's never I don't have the
audacity I don't want to disrespect the
audience someone who I don't feel
understands music the way I think we
understand music most of you when I say
we a lot of you people that know music
I'm just a music in like a pure human
sense meaning the lyrics the hook the
beat I very much understand that little
sandwich okay I understand it real well
so for example I know that I am a lyrics
guy like the reason hip-hop got me is
cuz I didn't come from [ __ ] cuz I've
always been underestimated people spit
my [ __ ] face I love competition like
I hate that I'm not a rapper because all
the [ __ ] that I really want to say I
can't the way a rapper can to me it's
the story this is why I [ __ ] [ __ ]
with biggie so much so the truth always
wins man the truth wins this what I say
the artists all-time they're like all
[ __ ] I need to get put on him huh if
your musics good enough especially in 20
[ __ ] 18 like put that [ __ ] on
soundcloud and spotify and show me [ __ ]
you nobody's stopping you you don't need
shame to put you on rotation
you don't need rap caviar to put you on
you don't if you're good enough you'll
eventually get there you might not be
poppin the way you think right now
the time Gary Vaynerchuk I appreciate
you so much man thank you so much thank
you you are a man who knows it all and
definitely definitely knows music Thank
You Ben yeah that was a pretty good
unimpressed money
[Music]